The earliest tools for roasting coffee beans
were pans you would hold over hot coals or an
open fire.
But today, coffee roasting is a far more
sophisticated process using large, often
fully automated machines with built in gas
burners that heat air to roast the beans.
This coffee roaster is both programmable and
manually adjustable by touch panel.
The roastmaster can tailor the temperature
and roasting time to influence flavor,
acidity and other characteristics of coffee
to shape the roast chamber workers feed a
sheet of stainless steel through a sheet
metal roll.
The roast chamber is the drum in which the
beans roast by convection heat.
The next step is to weld the rolled sheet
into a cylinder.
Then workers grind and polish the welds
until they're flat, smooth and shiny.
Another worker makes the cooling tray in a
similar way, but with a support band welded
to the top. The cooling tray is the drum
into which the hot beans drop when they exit
the rose chamber.
Stirring arms.
Circulate the beans as a fan draws air
through the tray to cool the hot beans.
Certain parts of the roaster are cut from a
stainless steel sheet.
Stainless steel is the ideal material, not
only because it's stylish, but also because
it's durable and corrosion resistant.
This computer guided laser cutter is slicing
out a safety component called the heat
shield, which prevents the roastmaster from
accidentally touching a hot surface.
The heat shield, like many other parts cut
from stainless steel sheets, has to be formed
to a very precise shape.
A worker bends angles and curves into the
metal with a press brake.
Another component the Trier lets you draw a
sample of beans during roasting.
A craftsman, constructs the Trier by welding
various smaller parts to a piece of stainless
steel tube, then meticulously grinding and
polishing the welds until they're smooth.
This high pressure water Jet cutter also
cuts parts from stainless steel sheets.
This component is one of six flights, which
is part of the paddle that lifts and mixes
the beans inside the roast chamber so that
they roast evenly.
To form the flights to the required shape.
A worker curves them one at a time in a
press.
Next, the welder places all the paddle
components into a specialized fixture which
positions them correctly.
First, he aligns the spokes to the paddle
shaft.
Then he welds the parts in place.
He positions the flights, clamps them
securely and welds them on.
The combination of inner and outer flights
lifts the beans into the airflow, ensuring
the beans roast evenly.
A custom designed, grinding machine hones
the flights to produce a small clearance of
around a 10th of an inch between the edge of
the paddle and the wall of the roast chamber.
This design ensures the paddle is wide
enough to pick up every last coffee bean
without touching the wall while rotating.
Once they install the paddle, a worker
closes up the rose chamber with a face plate.
Alignment pins, ensure the face plate is
properly positioned.
The paddle shaft protrudes through a bearing
in the face plate.
The assembly team uses a hoist to lift the
heavy chamber and position it on top of the
coffee roaster stainless steel support
frame.
They install the heat shield that was cut by
the laser cutter and bent to shape in the
press break. On top, the assembly team
mounts the machine's funnel shaped hopper.
The hopper feeds the unroasted coffee beans
to the roast chamber below.
The Hopper's lid has a tube which connects
to a vacuum system that draws the coffee
beans up through a plastic hose.
On the front of the roasting chamber, an
assembler hangs a hinged discharge door that
has a viewing window.
He plugs in a sensor that measures the
temperature of the beans in the roasting
chamber and sends that information to the
machine's computer.
This coffee roasting machine has three
additional temperature sensors that send data
to the computer.
These sensors measure the temperature of the
air entering and exiting the roast chamber
and the temperature of the clean air
exhausting from the machine after the burner,
incinerates the smoke generated by the
roasting process.
Workers continue assembly by installing the
cooling tray beneath the discharge door of
the roasting chamber.
The cooling tray sits on a support frame
which contains a motor that turns the
stirring arms inside the tray.
At the back of the machine, a worker
installs the trays, cooling fan and the motor
that drives it.
This cage measures the pressure of the air
that mixes with the gas going into the
machine's burner.
Next they installed the circulation fan.
The fan is designed to withstand high heat
and move air efficiently throughout the
coffee roaster.
The bottom end of the stainless steel tube
connects to a vacuum motor.
The top end connects to the tube protruding
from the feed hoppers lid.
To fill the roasting chamber, the vacuum
motor sucks the raw green coffee beans up
into the hopper, which drops the beans into
the chamber, where as they roast their papery
skin called, the chaff breaks off.
This separating device known as a cyclone
connects to the circulation fan.
The fan blows hot air returning from the
roasting chamber into the cyclone at high
velocity. The air circulates in a downward
spiral past the burner at the base of the
cyclone, incinerating the smoke.
This also draws the chaff out of the air
into a barrel nozzle spray water on the chaff
to prevent it from catching fire, which is a
common hazard with traditional coffee
roasters. The circulation fan then forces
the clean hot air up and out the top of the
cyclone through this S-shaped insulated air
duct back into the roasting chamber.
A technician in the factory's electrical
department, assembles the machine's control
panel, among other components.
The circuitry runs control systems and the
machine's six electric motors, which operate
moving parts such as the beam drawing vacuum
motor, the circulation fan, the cooling tray
fan, the roasting chamber paddle and cooling
tray.
Stirring arms.
Workers then install the control panel in a
cabinet on the side of the machine.
They connect all the wires.
They mount the machine's computer adjacent
to the control panel cabinet.
Next, a worker assembles the cooling tray
system.
A motor under the tray drives the stirring
arms.
The hot roasted coffee beans sit on top of
the stainless steel screen.
The cooling fan pulls ambient air through
the beans, down through the openings of the
screen, then out an exhaust pipe to the
outdoors.
The stirring arms, move the beans around so
that they cool quickly and evenly, which
prevents the beans from continuing to roast.
The factory runs every finished coffee
roaster through multiple test roasts.
After heating the roast chamber to a
specific temperature, the operator uses the
touch screen to release the beans into the
chamber.
The hot air travels from the cyclone to the
roast chamber, then through a return pipe
back to the cyclone where it's cleaned and
sent back to the chamber to know when to
manually end the roast cycle.
The operator views smells and listens to the
beans.
That's because coffee beans make crackling
noises as they expand and shed their chaff.
The machine can also be set to end the row
cycle automatically when the beans reach
their target temperature.
A trapdoor opens to draw in ambient air.
This cooler air pushes smoke in the roasting
chamber up to the cyclone for incineration.
The computer can automatically open the
roast chambers discharge door or the operator
can do so manually.
As soon as the roasted coffee beans drop
into the cooling tray.
The stirring arms and cooling fan
automatically start up if the beans are
perfectly roasted.
The machine is ready to be shipped to a
coffee roasting business.